make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i want to do something a
little bit dangerous
you know i know i'm a little bit late to
like the invincible stuff and all that
kind of stuff but i want to cover the
secret history of the viltrumite race
right like this stuff you don't know
because it's really cool right the
villager might race is super cool some
of these things you might see in season
two just fyi if you guys are trying to
avoid spoilers i mean i don't really
think it's anything major with regards
to like what direction the storyline
takes or anything like that it's just
like little things that you learn over
the course of the invincible series
right so
um so let's kind of start things back
with like the early days of the
viltromite race right so
what you had was a guy named lord argol
and this guy was the emperor right he
was the guy who ran the show the whole
nine yards
what ended up happening as we know and
as you guys have seen from the show or
if you've read the comics which i don't
know why you wouldn't be reading the
comics but you should buy and read the
comics uh what you end up getting here
is basically the the vulture might race
being transformed into
a kind of planet conquering race right
so like what if superman and the
kryptonians conquered worlds right
that's kind of what the answer to that
question is and so what ends up
happening here
is that there is opposition to the idea
of the viltromites conquering different
worlds right becoming this conquering
race and this opposition is led by a man
named
thaddeus and so thaddeus essentially
becomes the first
viltromite to essentially stand against
the throne which is
punishable by death but he's the first
person to stand against the throne and
then essentially incite rebellion
by gathering those people to his side
who are against what the vulture might
are doing
and then fighting and kind of waging a
war against the emperor we call this
the viltrumite civil war and so
following that
thaddeus was successful in killing lord
argol
but not before lord argol produced an
heir and so what ends up happening is
that thaddeus ultimately takes off as
soon as that happens because he knows
the entirety of the vulture might race
will come after him now understand
the viltrumite race does not have it out
for thaddeus because
thaddeus left them throneless they have
it out for him because he killed the
emperor one of the big things about the
vulture right race is
they don't really care who sits on the
throne they care about royal blood
right they are they they swear their
allegiance to the royal family
so if for example you have a character
who will talk about here in a minute if
you have a character who kind of steps
in
and basically killed lord argol himself
and then in turn
took the throne the viltrumites would
kill him because he's not actually of
royal blood and so in their mind he
doesn't deserve the right to rule
right so in the aftermath of this there
were a few things that happened right
the the existing numbers of the
viltromites that
that survived the civil war and the
purge were reduced even further
by something that was called the scourge
virus now the scourge virus was thought
up by what was referred to as the
coalition of planets and the coalition
of planets were formed by thaddeus that
when thaddeus defected
and then left viltrum after killing lord
argol he came to the realization
that it's likely somebody else is going
to rise to power
even if only in a temporary measure
until the heir of lord argol is found
and when that happens the vulture might
race will be back to business as usual
if they're not already continuing their
business at that point in time and so in
order to combat the influence and the
possibility of the vulture might race
conquering various worlds the coalition
of planets was formed as a means to
kind of offset that to travel around all
of creation
and gather individuals who are loyal to
the anti-viltrum
uh ideologies and then at the same time
find individuals powerful enough to
protect worlds from the viltrumites
themselves who could essentially fight
them off
as it was kind of like this secret war
that was taking place between these two
factions
behind the scenes now the scourge virus
itself did kind of come from the dna of
thaddeus and so the scourge virus
basically reduced the uh the viltrum
population all the way down to like less
than 50 right so there were basically
almost none left and so what the what
the vulture might race started doing is
they started working on the idea of
repopulating right kind of growing their
ranks and numbers back up
and all this happened under the purview
of what is definitively
the strongest viltromite and not just
the strongest vulture might but the
strongest one to
ever exist right so stronger than omni
man stronger than mark
stronger than all those guys this dude
comes in the form of a guy named
thrack and thrag is a
demon this guy is a he's he is a monster
to give you guys perspective on this
right to give you guys perspective on
what this guy can do
there's a point that comes in the story
when mark faces off against thrag and
goes to attack him
and nothing happens it does no good
whatsoever
nolan steps in and it's pretty much the
same thing right like no one's not
really able to do much damage to this
guy now eventually
battle beast shows up and battle b
starts facing off against thrag and the
two of them are actually super even like
it's it's kind of nuts and the battle
goes on for days
ultimately battle beast is defeated and
then thrag kind of just returns
and then works on sort of bringing their
numbers back up and and helping the
entire
uh you know vulture my population reach
uh reach a higher number so they can
actually
initiate a campaign in the aftermath of
what we called the viltrumite war
it's a cool concept right but that's
kind of what's going on behind the
scenes now
looking at a character like alan the
alien this guy's really interesting
because alan the alien is an experiment
that's the nature behind alan the alien
the idea was to essentially create a
race of people
that could stand against the viltrumites
they could either be equal or greater to
them
in power ultimately alan the alien is
the only one who really demonstrated any
measure of strength that was even
remotely close to the viltrumites he's
not as strong as them or at least he was
not originally but he was still stronger
than pretty much everybody
else now eventually his power starts to
grow as time goes on to the point where
he is actually equal to the viltrumites
in power but that's where alan the alien
comes from
everybody else that you see is just kind
of either characters who have joined
like guardians of the globe because
their own individual powers
uh characters who have joined the
coalition of planets like for example
battle beast ends up becoming part of
the coalition of planets but but yeah
like there's a lot that goes on
in the invincible comics here's the
question that i kind of have for you
guys do you want to see me cover these
invincible characters right like are you
guys interested in that kind of stuff i
don't know if you guys want me to do
like you know omni man explain
invincible explained any of that kind of
stuff i'm kind of curious but it's cool
right it's
it's an it's a super interesting set of
events but thrag to kind of kind of you
know
uh nip this and to focus on this a
little bit more thrag is the answer to
the question
who is the most powerful of the
viltromites that exist out there right
like who's the most powerful
of all those guys it really is him right
it really is that guy his power is
is absolute there does come a point when
ultimately he
is turned on by the viltrumites and
again this is a pretty cool moment when
it happens
but he's probably also one of the more
interesting characters in invincible i
think if i'm being honest i know this is
going to be kind of a dangerous game
i think he's more interesting than
omniman and mark but i think he's more
interesting than both of those guys he
doesn't really have as much character
development because he's not he's not
around nearly as long as the rest of
those guys but i think he is more
interesting
than pretty much any of those guys but
that's kind of the secret history
of the vulture mites again like you know
invention is only 144 issues long right
so there's not
there's really more focus that's put on
a lot of the characters who exist out
there now
than there is and pretty much anybody
else but let me know what you guys think
right do you guys want me to expand on
these characters you want me to expand
on on all the different members of the
roster
and the characters that we have yet to
see let me know down in the comment
section uh but if you guys are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop
a like and i will catch you all later
peace
you